so keeping with our series of videos on
secret Wars we pick up now with Secret
Wars number two and I want to you guys
right now this is a damn good story the
silver sticker or ember one concluded
with the end of everything the end of
the Marvel multiverse and the
destruction of presumably a multitude of
characters Secret Wars number two picks
up with the beginning of battle world
with the beginning of everything now as
we get into this video what I want to
make clear here is that some of the
things that we're going to see in this
video we're simply just not going to
have answers to yet we don't know what a
lot of these things will turn into and
so while I'm sure you guys will have a
lot of questions I'll answer them as
best I can but some of them we just
don't have an answer to what I also want
to want you guys to keep in mind here is
that the notion of alternate realities
is no longer part of the equation that
there are no more there's no more
earth-616 there's no more ultimate
universe there's no more Marvel Zombies
universe none of that stuff and said
there's simply just bad a world and so
over the course of this video while I
referenced things like earth-616 and
while I referenced things like the
ultimate universe that's simply just to
give you guys perspective that's to help
you guys understand these characters and
reference to who they used to be as
opposed to who they are now so what we
do as we start this series is we pick up
with some young man who has successfully
lifted the hammer four which is
basically our introduction to the Thor
core as is explained to us by Odin Thor
who appears to be basically the leader
of the Thor core the Thor core is
essentially the police force of battle
world and they carry out the will of the
god of rattle world or of this reality
who's actually revealed to us to be
Doctor Doom and what we also do is we
join Odin for as he takes this newest
recruit of the Thor Corps on a tour of
battle world what we're given is this
sort of origin story where prior to the
existence of battle world there was
nothing and then everything came into
existence presumably at the hands of
Doctor Doom what's it's basically
telling us here is that the Thor Corps
are pretty much unaware of anything
having ever existed before the end of
the Marvel multiverse in the
establishment of battle world now again
we don't know this for a fact this just
appears to be the case more so than that
we don't know if anybody else on battle
world believes this at this moment is
simply just given to us
this seems to be the perspective of the
third core but what we do is we find
that in the keynote of you topless we
actually move away from the four core
here and we find that we pick up with
the Captain Britain core and the Captain
Britain core under this under the
kingdom of you topless appear to have
several scientists that have uncovered
some kind of a vessel and this vessel
appears to be the RAF that was used by
Reed Richards and the various heroes
from earth-616 to escape the collapse of
that universe the destruction of
everything and survive into the I guess
the the creation of battle world and
this new reality now from here we
rejoined I guess Odin Thor we pick up
with his character and this recruit as
they arrive at bars finished which is
the kingdom of mr. sinister then again
as they basically exist to carry out the
law of doom this is what they're doing
what we're told is that sinister has
been ordered in the I guess order to the
presence to appear before dr. doom
himself and again this really seems to
give us some very I guess a large amount
of insight into the world the Doctor
Doom plays as the god of battle world in
the sense that it seems as though Doctor
Doom is really believed to be this kind
of God because what happens here this
sinister makes no attempt to refuse the
order to appear before doom and the
earth-616 continuity sinister was a
character who really didn't know didn't
take orders from anybody he will just
kind of did his own thing but in this
circumstance when he's ordered to appear
before Doctor Doom while he is very
cavalier about it while he has a lot of
attitude about it he still does it and
so the second thing that we learned here
is that it appears that models basically
chosen some of the most prominent
villains from the earth-616 continuity
to be the leaders of is to be the leader
of these different these different
kingdoms within battle world of course
mr. sinister being one of the more
prominent members of our 6-1-6 is the
leader of bar sinister itself and so
again what we find is that we basically
pick up with the arrival of the Thor
Corps and was referred to as doom stat
which is the home of Doctor Doom and it
appears as though this place is guarded
by some form of Galactus now this is a
little bit different from the Galactus
that we're used to in the sense that
this version of Galactus is on fire he
has a fiery head and so on and so forth
but again this will just appears to be
some version of the go
like this character and at some point
along the line we may get a little more
information about this but what we end
up doing here is once we join doom
inside I guess join either Thor Corps
incidents are inside of Doom stat Doctor
Strange is revealed to us to be the
sheriff of battle world who basically
upholds the laws of doom across all of
the kingdoms there for any reason a
dispute arises between the rulers of
these various kingdoms the dispute
itself is settled within the house of
Doom in order to basically maintain
peace and to keep Kingdom from waging
war against each other and evolving
battle world into a state of chaos what
we're told is that sinister apparently
has allied himself with Hyperion the
ruler of the kingdom of the the squadron
supreme and that the intention of them
seems to be to overthrow Jamie Braddock
who is a leader of you topless now as a
result Jimmy Braddock is basically
requested a hearing in front of Doctor
Doom to settle this to settle this
matter to settle this dispute but the
problem is that while sinister basically
lies to maintain his innocence he's
eventually found guilty by dr. strange
and so as a result sinister basically
chooses to challenge Brian Braddock the
brother of Jamie Braddock to a battle to
the death now while we're told that
sinister has the right to earn his
innocence by battling someone to the
death were not told why he's able to
challenge Brian Braddock instead of the
person who's accusing him Jamie Braddock
but I'd go as far as to say here that it
most likely because sinister is a
representation of his own territory or
possibly because he's the one being
challenged he has the right to challenge
anybody from the kingdom is challenging
him and so in this instance he chose a
child challenge Brian Braddock but again
I don't really have any confirmation for
this I have no real basis for this is
just kind of a theory on my part there's
I want to make this make sense in my own
mind but regardless the result is that
during the fight sinister appears to be
victorious but before he's able to deal
the deal the killing blow he's basically
stalked by dr. doom and the reason for
this is I guess his doom explains
because dooms basically uncovered some
knowledge which indicates that there are
individuals who have been plotting
against his position and that these
individuals may exist inside the kingdom
of you topless
and so while Jimmy Braddock claims a
lack of knowledge well he says he
doesn't really know anything about this
what doom says is that if Jamie Braddock
is the ruler of
appleís then as a king of that area he
should know everything that's going on
within his kingdom and that failure to
achieve this failure to do so means that
he's basically not fit to be the king
and so the result is that doom at the
behest of Susan storm has Jamie Braddock
taken away Brian Braddock elevated to
the position of the king of you topless
and sinister sentenced to a series of
lashes now what I want to do here is I
want to take a break from this entire
segment for a second and I want to talk
about Susan storm and the reason why is
because as we know with Secret Wars
number one it appeared that all of the
members of the Fantastic Four with the
exception of Reed Richards had been
killed when the universe collapsed when
their lifeboat had basically kind of
broken away and so on but it appears
that dr. doom has saved them and so
while we don't really know where Ben
Grimm or where Johnny Storm is what we
do know is that Franklin Richards
filaria Richards and Susan storm are
alive now we don't know if some of the
other individuals that we've seen for
example mr. sinister or some of those
other characters were saved by dr. doom
we simply just know that they're here
but regardless what we do here is we
pick up with the Thor Corps as they
prepare to deliver Jimmy Braddock to his
fate after having after Jimmy Braddock
was basically sentenced by Doctor Doom
and what happens is the group arrives at
the shield wall which appears to be a
giant wall stretching the entire length
of battle world which seems very similar
to the Great Wall of China here but what
happens is Jamie Braddock being
sentenced is basically thrown over the
wall and so what we learn is that on the
other side of this wall which is
designed to isolate or to protect all
the kingdoms of battle world there
consists three groups the first group
are the zombies from the Marvel Zombie
universe the second group is the
annihilation wave and Annihilus himself
and the third group is appears to be
just a vast number of robots now what
Odin basically tells his recruit here is
that it appears as though somewhere
along the line that when this wall was
built that various people had been
placed there to defend it and they've
been defending it for years and that
people had died so again it seems as
though if doom really did create battle
world if he really did create this
reality then perhaps he planted the
thoughts in the minds of all it'san
happened so they've been here for as
long as they can remember
that for some reason this is really just
kind of a temporal thing again this is
really kind of confusing here and we
don't really have an answer to this
question although I'm sure that as time
progresses we'll understand why it is
that Odin Thor believes that he's been
here for years when in fact this isn't
the case and the reason why this is not
the case is because what happens is we
jump back to the scientist from the
kingdom of Utah police who are
investigating this raft that appeared to
belong to the survivors of earth-616 but
what's revealed to us is that the thor
core or at least a small contingent of
the thor core had been assigned here to
basically bring an end to this
excavation to take all the items that
have been uncovered by the scientists
and to take them back to to castle doom
but when does up happening is one of the
scientists basically opens this raft
opens the ship and when it does it's
revealed to us this is not the ship that
belongs to earth-616 instead it's the
ship that belonged to the ultimate
universe to the ultimate universe Reed
Richards Thanos and the Cabal and so
what happens is thousand the Cabal come
out and immediately incapacitate this
small contingent of the Thor core we
didn't see the Thanos is basically
confused about where he's at he is
understand where this world is how this
world got there or how they even got
there and so what happens if Thanos
basically questions the scientists and
the scientist says that while this place
is referred to under a multitude of
different names depending on who it is
that you're talking to it's a highborn
is referred to as as one name if it is a
common person they refer to it as
battleworld
what this basically means here is that
either a very long amount of time is
passed between the collapse of the
universe and the birth of this new
universe which would explain why Odin
says that or why Odin Thor says that
they've been protecting it for years or
it could simply just be that almost no
time has passed this reality came into
existence and then now Thanos and these
individuals are coming out of the raft
again this is a little confusing here
but again as we continue with the secret
war story this will all be made to make
sense I have no doubt about that with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace
don't forget me now I don't wanna fade
out of your memory you'll never be happy
no I am I